bom dia muito bom tá aqui com vocês hoje
para falar de dois assuntos que eu sou
realmente apaixonada 1 educação e outro
é a tecnologia
quem aqui e não tem momentos marcantes
na vida seja na educação na sua família
eu tenho alguns que me fizeram o que eu
sou hoje eu queria compartilhar com
vocês um pouco isso
quando eu era pequena
uma das coisas que eu mais gostava eu e
minha irmã era quando a gente voltava da
escola ea gente inventou de transformar
o nosso quintal de casa
na minha sala de aula ea gente tem uma
parede branca nosso quintal e uma das
coisas que a gente inventou foi pegar
descolorido azul rosa e começar a
escrever na parede e é incrível aquele
momento porque era um momento que eu
estava ensinando meus amigos imaginários
junto com a minha irmã
meus alunos e imaginários e aprendendo
também da mesma forma
minha mãe como a professora educadora
sempre incentivou a gente fazer isso e
ea gente acabava se envolvendo naquele
momento bom
anos depois é eu numa aula este é um
momento marcante e anos depois numa aula
eu entro em uma aula de ciências e aí
realmente aquilo foi um choque pra mim e
aquilo me marcou demais e me lembro até
hoje era uma professora alta ela tinha
um cabelo loiro óculos grandes e aquela
era uma aula onde ela estava
apresentando pra gente do que a gente
era feito de matéria de moléculas e
átomos
ela apresentou para a gente a tabela
periódica gente aquilo lá pra mim parece
pouco mas foi realmente impactante
eu fui pra casa naquele dia pensando que
a gente é feito incrível alguém olhou
é a gente é a energia a todos dispostos
em uma lógica bom na aula seguinte eu já
tava
é com memorizando os átomos números
atômicos que família estavam
eu só estava no sexto ano aquilo que me
marcou demais
e aí eu fui seguindo minha carreira
coincidência ou não eu acabei escolhendo
a minha primeira profissão que não é
hoje a profissão que eu exerço eu acabei
por escolher a primeira profissão
olhando para o lado da saúde e resolvi
na sequência fiz odontologia e não cursa
não exerci mas eu fui ser cientista
então fui fazer meu mestrado e doutorado
em bioquímica
naquela mesma história que ouvia na
tabela periódica e foi é muito incrível
porque naquele momento é que eu estava
estudando a a tabela periódica e eu
envolvi na área de bioquímica
foi um momento muito especial porque eu
acabei pensando exatamente na nossa
existência
a gente existe a terra existe há quatro
e meio bilhões de anos
esse é o tempo que nós estamos aqui que
a terra se conhece como é hoje
e de novo mais um elemento surge mais um
elemento surge na minha vida que é o
oxigênio eo oxigênio ele foi fundamental
para que nós nos desenvolvêssemos como
organismos mais complexos
então aquele mesmo elemento que não 6º
ano fazer começou a fazer sentido pra
mim lá mais para a frente onde estudei
fazer mais sentido ainda até a gente se
desenvolver como ser humano como a gente
se conhece hoje
e por falar em ser humano nós estamos
aqui há 200 mil anos e durante esses 200
mil anos a gente desenvolveu diferentes
hábitos diferentes formas de interação
entre nós ea gente também desenvolveu a
ciência ea tecnologia ea ciência ea
tecnologia movem o mundo há 200 mil anos
pensar vamos pular um pouquinho vários
mil anos a gente em mais ou menos na
década de 1940
cientistas começaram a estudar será que
uma máquina pode pensar como um ser
humano
será que uma máquina é capaz de entender
simular o comportamento humano e aí
surgiram as primeiras pesquisas nessa
área e essa área
ela evoluiu demais e mas em 1950 um
ponto bastante interessante um
pesquisador ele desenvolveu ele publicou
um artigo no ano de 1950 onde ele
mostrava um teste ele punha um ser
humano e interagindo com máquinas e
seres humanos e se uma máquina
interagindo com esse ser humano esse ser
humano não entendesse que era uma
máquina então essa máquina passava no
teste
esse foi o teste de turing e foi o
primeiro teste que se falou sobre
inteligência artificial e desde então a
inteligência artificial vem acelerando
demais
hoje ela é capaz de fazer reconhecimento
facial inclusive de gêmeos idênticos
ela é capaz de analisar o sentimento de
um grupo de pessoas saber se aquele um
tema está sendo bem visto ou não tão bem
visto para as pessoas
a inteligência artificial é capaz de
analisar a personalidade da pessoa
trazer traços da personalidade dessa
pessoa com base porque porque cientistas
ensinaram essa inteligência artificial
no na metodologia do bife capaz de com
acerta é confiança dizer esses traços
hoje a gente é capaz de falar em
linguagem natural
a inteligência artificial entender essa
linguagem é natural transportado por um
texto analisar um tema e retornar pra
você com uma voz sintética e sintetizar
a voz então aquilo que começou lá em
cinquenta e depois demorou mais menos 50
60 anos para as empresas entenderem que
isso era uma oportunidade de mercado
agora o que essa inteligência artificial
essa oportunidade essa tecnologia tem a
ver com a educação
então agora eu convido vocês pra
imaginar da mesma forma que eu fazia meu
quintal
vamos imaginar que a eu estou numa sala
de aula
eu sou professora eu tenho um aluno aqui
que está vendo um vídeo eu tenho três
grupos que estão discutindo assuntos eu
tenho um aluno que está lendo aí dois
alunos entram na sala de aula eu tenho
meu professor virtual
esse professor virtual diz maria você é
uma menina introvertida gosta de estudar
lendo então ela vai e segue o seu canto
e ela vai ler o pedro que entra na
sequência é um menino muito extrovertido
que aprendi
junto com os colegas e o pedro vai e se
une a um grupo primeiro pra ele
isto dá aquele assunto através de um
grupo eu professora
vou passar pelos alunos e vou verificar
o comportamento o desenvolvimento e hoje
é possível agora vamos pensar aqui
comigo
a escola hoje faz isso ela consegue
verificar a diferença entre o pedro é
maria
se o pedro hosken de mais de manhã e se
chamaria rende mais à noite
se as relações entre os alunos estão
boas
se a gente está olhando para o potencial
de cada aluno
será que a gente hoje consegue no
formato de sala de aula no nosso
conceito a gente consegue dar conta da
diversidade das particularidades de cada
um assim como eu lá atrás
fiquei encantada e realmente queria
muito trabalhar a consciência
será que a gente está encantando as
nossas crianças
ou será que a gente está tratando todo
mundo igual
o que não é igual será que a gente está
usando as tecnologias ao nosso favor
hoje a gente tem que acreditar que a
tecnologia que foi desenvolvida por nós
seres humanos
a gente não pode ter medo dela ela é
nossa aliada ela veio pra aumentar as
nossas capacidades humanas
se a gente foi capaz 200 mil anos
evoluir e nas últimas décadas
exponenciar e aumentar muito o nosso
nossa capacidade de interagir com os
sistemas inteligentes como que está
sendo pensado nosso futuro como que a
gente está pensando o futuro
ou será que a gente está acomodado e tá
mudando a passos lentos
enquanto a tecnologia avança a passos
largos
hoje a gente tem que ser mais
protagonista dessa mudança e talvez a
gente tenha que mudar muito mais rápido
a nossa educação do que a gente está
mudando assim como eu lá atrás
entrei numa sala de aula e ficava
encantada com a primeira tecnologia que
eu tive contato que foi uma tabela
periódica
eu fico imaginando que potencial nós
temos os alunos poderem interagir com
assistentes virtuais eles próprios
criarem seus assistentes virtuais ea
gente poder ter mais tempo para aquilo
que é nosso do ser humano que são as
relações pessoais que são agente
fomentar a criatividade a inovação o
trabalho em equipe a gente entender as
nossas relações entre os seres humanos
ea gente deixa para os sistemas para as
máquinas para que eles façam aquilo que
a gente repetitivo que a gente não
deveria fazer e que as máquinas deveriam
fazer a gente está vivendo uma nova era
uma nova era onde a nossa relação com os
sistemas vai mudar e já mudou
completamente o que a gente não pode
deixar a educação lá atrás onde ela
surgiu a gente tem que evoluir junto eu
esse é o meu minha causa
a gente tem que levar informação
desmistificar é o que é inteligência
artificial desmistifica
toda essa relação dessas novas
tecnologias com estudantes e
principalmente com os professores e cada
um de nós a gente tem que ser
protagonista
pra que a gente viva os próximos x anos
que não sabemos de uma forma mais justa
mais igual e mais sustentável dentro de
uma sociedade e sermos aqueles seres
humanos que queremos numa sociedade
muito mais igual
muito obrigada